so how did you get involved in this
initially like
initially i wanted a video series like
mine to exist but no one had it around
so i decided to make it myself yeah yeah
fair enough fair enough yeah
no because like i i i guess what uh what
what uh motivated you to get into this
kind of because it seems like there's an
entire culture around chris chan right
now
story stories called christopher chris
is a person who knows pretty much
everything about it who is a part of
christopher
[Laughter]
i just couldn't imagine someone
unironically being like i am a christian
yes
do you i mean are you technically one do
you refer to yourself as one or does it
matter
people are referred to me as the go to
chris jordan at the moment yeah
so it sounds
contempt when
you know those memes where it's like the
people holding up like the world the
army and it's
they're living like peacefully at the
top it's like gino samuel
hate many aspects of it is that fair to
say um
i wish there was something more to my
identity rather than being a christian
right right of course you know but yeah
of course i can't blame them because it
is like the thing that i'm most known
for at the moment at least it's all it's
also it is just so i think when a lot of
people see that you've made 40 hours or
nearly 60 episodes on something they do
think
uh what drives a man to do such a thing
to make 60 episodes and i think if i
remember correctly when you've been
doing this um your channel got deleted
at some point right yeah so your channel
is called geno samuel 2.1 plug link in
the description um so i think because it
got deleted during the first ones that
correct yes you know samuel 2 was
terminated for bullying and harassment
right that was for the christian
that was the christian episodes i was up
to part 12 at that point yeah i think
this yeah i think i remember this
happening and i thought you were gonna
quit right at that point at some point
no yeah i did quit um actually made part
13 and then released it on on a
different video hosting platform but
then after that i decided you know what
i'm just not going to do this anymore
yeah yeah because what i want to know is
did you know what you're getting
yourself into when you started this
project
well at around part five i got already
10 000 subs on on youtube so for that i
made a q a video right answered some
questions
and uh people asked how long do you
think it's going to be i said i'm
probably going to get up to date around
part 15.
so
i really had no idea
well yeah because it's just insane that
you know because like
because again i've seen a couple of your
episodes right and it's and it's just
insane because it's like one episode
isn't just talking about like one
core thing it's right it's like it's
just a compilation of all the things
that just happen in chronological order
so
like on average like how long does it
take to make one christian episode uh
from the start of writing to the
publication maybe three to four weeks
oh my god i mean yeah like i can't think
of the amount of research that has to go
into her right
what is your research process for this i
i wouldn't even know how or where to
start yeah do you talk to a lot of
people in the community do you ask them
hey what happened if you're not sure or
like what is the whole process um very
rarely i do talk with someone but mostly
go through the quickie and then the qb
farms
kiwi farms is a certain uh website
which is
which is focusing on discussions around
people online who do
laughable things
and um are affectionately or
unaffectionately referred to as lol cows
yeah because there's a whole website
called lol as well right which is
separate that's a that's a different
thing yeah so definitely a different
website but that is like the type of
person generally someone who just makes
a lot of drama uh does a lot of very
questionable things yeah my
understanding of uh like uh kiwi farms
and low cal was always just like a place
where people go to like talk drama about
certain people and like yeah where i
feel like 4chan is just unfiltered
garbage that is sometimes funny but also
extremely questionable i feel like uh
lol cow cube if i'm very centered on the
creators online and very much about
people who are doing stuff online
whereas four channels just anything yeah
anything goes yeah it wasn't was it
correct me if i'm wrong wasn't kiwi
farms started
like for chris like to document chris
yes yeah yeah it was originally called
wow quickie forums
did you not know that i did not know
okay well that's well there you go so
yeah
yeah it was originally called
quickyforms and uh the reason it's it um
developed into kv forms was because it
was during uh during a certain dry spell
of content from from christian when they
were not being active online for like a
year or so people started making sub
forms about other people who are similar
to chris and then after a while they
decided to abandon the quickie forms and
then
get a new domain and call themselves
kiwi farms which is apparently
um a result it's like it's actually
based on a mispronunciation that some
that some other lol cows said about the
quickie forms that they pronounced
that's how it started and so uh quick is
uh
is that just this christian western
christian western chandler which is the
name cwc
and that and that is uh essentially the
universe or like what is that what
christine bill is that
correct me on the law there's so much
information it's very hard to keep track
yes chris uh started building their own
world um i guess during their teenage
years in the late late 90s they
developed this concept of quakeville
which is which is the city of quick
christian
i'm i'm so there is there is like this
this is like this whole fantastical
world so fantastic exactly do you know
what sonichu is
no
what do you want to explain what sonichu
is well i mean it's very easy i mean
yeah okay so i think quickball was
actually before sonichu so it was just
like right
into there but yeah solitude came about
as as a high school project
um chris was doing
a design class where he had to design
his own cd
and he wanted to put on sonic and
pikachu the camera was a sonic or
pikachu and the teacher said he couldn't
put in any copyrighted characters right
so he decided to go around that issue
combine sonic and pikachu into sonichu
and that came with a very iconic meme
online yeah so i found out about the
whole chris thing because i knew what
sonichu was because like like you know
being on all sorts of internet forums
back in the day like you would just see
sonichu like out of context or you know
used insulin yeah i remember i saw it a
lot i had no no i just thought it was a
ripoff yes right so i thought it was
just like you know one of those like
funny memes that someone created right
and then i realized oh sonichu is linked
with this person called chris chan and
then that's how i found out about the
whole world of chris and then i just
went deeper and deeper into the rabbit
hole essentially so you know when you
watch your documentary uh it starts out
you know
uh i mean quite positive i'd say well
not positive but you know yeah i'd say
hopeful you know you you get a you get
introduced to uh uh chris at the time
and
it kind of becomes this like you know
you get to see chris on tv uh when very
young right when they won a competition
and you're like oh okay it's going
pretty well and then you start to get
into uh some very personal details about
chris which i always found very
concerning how they were like how did
you get this information because there's
when you get introduced to chris you you
learn about chris you learned that chris
is autistic uh that that chris is very
obsessed with games and stuff and then
somehow we we get a very detailed
explanation of chris's school life how
they had at the time uh multiple gal
pals as uh chris always refers to them
as uh who then we are found out later
they were
the chris's parents were
asked the gal pals to be friends with
chris
so that chris had friends there was just
like so much
personal intimate detail that i don't
even think i have about my own life yeah
right there was like uh
a medical record or something or a
psychiatric psychiatric evaluation right
how was this episode you showed this in
the in your episode of chris and i just
sat there in awe being like i don't even
know where mine is yeah if i have one i
don't you know like
that should be like publicly was this
all self-published by chris um some of
it was the documents the school papers
the medical records were actually like i
guess
illegally taken from their from their
property oh wow
yeah
um it was um it was a at a point much
later in their life around 2014 actually
there was a there was a troll who who
got into their their dumpster
and took out all the papers
yeah [ __ ] you know so people people have
been going to
uh chris's house and just dumpster
diving constantly and just trying to
happen at least once i don't think many
people did that yeah it's kind of crazy
just one time yeah but but but people do
go there and take updated pictures of
the house for example and they're right
and their lawn yeah